[Musique]
cette fois c'est donc cet oléoduc jusque
là invisibles sous la step de la crau
qui a failli désastre écologique au
coeur d'une réserve naturelle
malheureusement prévisible selon les
défenseurs de l'environnement
je suis effondrée parce que je crois
qu'il ya un manque d'attention de
lucidité et de responsabilité de la part
des industriels qui en loire atlantique
à donges ont des canalisations qui pète
qui dans la crau etc
ça veut dire qu'il ya pas un suivi
sérieux la france compte plus de
cinquante mille kilomètres de pipelines
36500 véhicule du gaz 9800 des
hydrocarbures le reste des produits
chimiques même s'il reste plus sûres que
les transports routiers ou ferroviaires
et 'pipeline' enregistre 20 fuite par an
un accident grave tous les cinq ans et
le réseau vieillit pour la plupart les
canalisations été construite dans les
années 50 et 60
vérifier l'intégralité du réseau travail
considérable mais nécessaire pour éviter
de futures pollution l'oléoduc de la
plaine de la crau n'avait pas été révisé
depuis neuf ans
[Musique]